ladies and gentlemen the 45th and final
President of the United States unspoken
so spooky happy Halloween to all the
haters and losers mr. president how do
you respond to criticisms from
Republican senators corker and flake
those guys are total zeroes but they
just voted with you to protect big banks
I just said those guys are American
heroes are you afraid that more
Republicans will turn against you no I'm
not afraid of then I'm the scary one and
that's why tonight's theme is fear as
president JFK Rowling once famously said
the only thing we have to fear is me yes
it is you'll see it's in the
super-secret JFK files there's great
stuff in there grassy knolls
hot centerfolds Lee Harvey Weinstein
significant resources to fixing the
opioid crisis we're gonna do it next
week you said you said that last week
that was an announcement about this week
and now I'm announcing next week's
announcement we're announcing so much
everyone's gonna be addicted to
announcements opioid crisis saw end of
discussion the microphone was on but
something was definitely off imagine if
you will a man man's so cruel so petty
so ignorant of government policy he
would be qualified to serve as dog
catcher but he just happens to be the
most powerful man in the world he uses
fear to control his enemies and
what happens when he loses that control
he'll soon find out because he's the
president can you believe it that's